Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters with Section 6 of the Meeting Chronic Lime Book.
Last section, we started on different neurological issues that you can have with Lyme disease.
So this issue, this section you're going to learn about what actually happens with that neurological damage.
So, wherever we said there's different type of glial cells, all of your brain cells you have neurons and you have glial cells.
The glial cells are separated into different types of glial cells.
What are the types of glial cells that astrocytes surround the blood vessels, parts of them do, and create a barrier between the blood and the brain to keep things from getting to the brain that shouldn't be getting to the brain, like Lyme disease.
So, if there's a breakdown of that astrocyte blood brain barrier, then bad things get into the brain, like Lyme disease, and we have a pickle on our head.
The microglial cells are really responsible for your immune response in the brain, and when you have activated microglial cells, like you would in Lyme disease, it could cause all sorts of problems with inflammation, you could break inflammation.
But also, you could have direct damage from the Lyme disease and indirect damage from the Lyme disease to the really, really maybe important, though I never say the glial cells aren't important.
So, the neurons are what carry information from one part of it to another, and then communicate to the next neuron, and it can bring information.
So, if I want to raise my hand, I am firing neurons in the opposite brain, frontal lobe, pre-motor cortex to the water cortex to don't, it's complicated.
So, those neurons are fired in order for me to fire a muscle in order to raise my hand.
So, the neurons also have a glial connection, because there's another type of glial cell on the neuron, that's for the myelin sheet, those are the called ologodendrocytes.
So, the ologodendrocytes form a myelin sheet, and the purpose of the myelin sheet, you could think of it as like an insulation around the neurons, so that communication, that neurological, electrical, firing could go much, much, much faster.
So, the reason why I could quickly move my hand when I want to move my hand is because I have myelinated nerves.
So, those, that nerve myelination is so, so important. So, when I get demilination, then my nerves don't work correctly.
So, there are certain diseases that cause demilination, the most notable is MS, and ALS. So, really, the real only difference between those two diseases is where the nerves are being demilinated, which nerves are being demilinated.
But, if you have rapid demilination, you have rapid disease process, going on, and you have rapid loss of function.
So, you could have a direct attack on the myelin sheet by a bacteria, like Lyme disease.
Typically, you don't have a direct attack, you have, you move into the autoimmune stage, so this is even worse.
You have, you have created antibodies to your old oligodendrocytes, your old myelin sheet, and now every time you fire in immune response, your TH1 and your TH17 cells are basically destroyed your myelin sheet.
So, we're going to go into how you treat this, and sometimes even more importantly, what you do not do, if you have an autoimmune, Lyme, or any autoimmune disease, because you don't want to add to the destruction of your myelin sheet.
So, very, very important there. So, top right here is, shows a myelin sheet that's being destroyed, and you start to get these neurological disorders, like in this person's face, they have a facial paralysis.
So, this is of the cranial nerve 7, person's sticking their tongue out, they have a paralysis of cranial nerve 12, you see difference in their brain skin on the left hand side, this is the ALS patient, where there's just overall degeneration in neural tissue.
This is where it becomes very serious in you, there's, in all Lyme disease has the ability to progress to this point, and you do not want it to progress to this point, so you better know what you're doing to treat it.
You cannot treat an autoimmune Lyme disease the same way you treat a chronic Lyme disease. Scream that from the rooftop, you'll learn what we're talking about as we go in here.
Again, this is a picture of the last line that I had at the last little talk. It talks about the different symptoms.
Go through the book on the symptoms and check what you have. It's important because it can really give you an idea where you're at.
You know, understand, I did this whole program because one of the biggest things that I got when I lectured to Lyme patients is that, you know, they're broke, they've used up every said that they have tried to treat it for the last 6, 8, 12, 14 years, they don't know what else to do, so I'm trying to give you as much information as possible.
So I just can't treat people for free. I just can't do that. We're too busy. So I'm trying to give you as much information as possible that you could treat it.
If you have a lot of these symptoms, I've given you a lot of ideas. If you have some of these symptoms, you are probably autoimmune, and you have to treat it that way.
So stay tuned. We're going to continue to dig into this. I hope you get a lot out of this. If it's a new idea, listen to it again.
If you got Lyme breed, listen to it about 50 times. I understand. I've had Lyme twice too, and I have a lot of Lyme patients. So we'll see you at the next section.